[Musik]
seit Jahrzehnten die gleiche Leier
Fachkräftemangel in Deutschland
Arbeitgeber beschweren sich kein
geeignetes Personal zu finden Angebote
und nachfrageklappe auseinander und die
Politik stimmt seit Jahren zu
Fachkräftebedarf das Thema
Fachkräftemangel droht Fachkräftemangel
zu einer dauerhaften Wachstumsbremse
Deutschland zu werden doch renommierte
Ökonomen widersprechen
Fachkräftemangel gibt es nicht die
Arbeitskräfte sind nicht weg die sind
nur woanders wo sind die Arbeitskräfte
Beispiel Friseurhandwerk seit
Jahrzehnten wird über Personal Lücken
geklagt darunter auch Friseursalon
tietzmann in Bonn bis die Inhaberin auf
die Idee kam die Arbeitsbedingungen zu
verändern ich habe die vier Tage Woche
eingeführt und habe auf drei Stunden in
der Woche verzichtet um das sehr gut
hinzubekommen und seitdem habe ich
überhaupt gar keine Probleme mehr keine
Wochenendarbeit längere Öffnungszeiten
an zwei Tagen das Modell kommt an
plötzlich ist es umgekehrt es gibt mehr
Bewerber als offene Stellen wir haben in
Deutschland keinen Fachkräftemangel weil
wir so viele Beschäftigte haben wie noch
nie die Beschäftigten sind insbesondere
dort weggegangen wo Arbeitsbedingungen
schlecht waren wo Löhne niedrig waren
und sind jetzt dort wo Löhne tendenziell
besser sind Arbeitsbedingungen besser
sind Beispiel Pflegekräfte eine Studie
der Arbeitnehmerkammer Bremen hat
errechnet dass
860.000 Pflege aus ihrem erlernten Beruf
ausgestiegen sind 60% wären allerdings
bereits zurückzukehren wenn sich
Arbeitsbedingungen und Lohn verbesserten
hochgerechnet während das
260.000 Vollzeitkräfte
darüber sprechen Arbeitgeber seltener
sie klagen lieber über Fachkräftemangel
das ist eine Erzählung der Wirtschaft
die wir schon seit vielen Jahren hören
aber wir müssen eben auch sehen dass
viele Deutsche jedes Jahr das Land
verlassen dass viele in teilzeitarbeiten
obwohl sie Vollzeit arbeiten könnten
dass viele in Arbeitslosigkeit stecken
obwohl sie erwerbsfähig sind wir haben
sehr viele Potenziale in Deutschland die
nicht genutzt werden der Staat hat viel
zu lange drauf gesetzt das Arbeitskräfte
billig sein müssen und auch das Thema
das ganze Thema aus und Weiterbildung
völlig vernachlässigt und man sieht es
ja auch jetzt in der Finanzminister sagt
oder muss man gucken ist erstmal das
Geld für weitere Qualifizierung da das
ist ein völlig falschen Ende gespart
Bildung und Qualifizierung sind
Investitionen in die Zukunft noch nie
gab es so viele Arbeitnehmer wie heute
mehr als 41 Millionen Angestellte davon
allerdings
38,8 % in Teilzeit jeder fünfte im
Niedriglohnsektor darunter sechseinhalb
Millionen Minijobber die Mehrzahl Frauen
die Erhöhung der Verdienstgrenze von 4
50 auf 520 Euro ist volkswirtschaftlich
Gift auszubrechen lohnt nicht
verheiratete in Steuerklasse 5 würden
trotz Mehrarbeit erst einmal weniger
verdienen wenn wir ein Reformpaket
durchführen würden das im
Niedriglohnbereich Anreize stärkt
Vollzeit zu arbeiten wenn wir vom
Ehegattensplitting übergehen würden zu
einem real splitting dann könnten wir
insgesamt ungefähr 200.000 Vollzeit
Arbeitsplätze gewinnen seit einem halben
Jahr läuft dieser Friseursalon in Bonn
wieder rund zufriedene Mitarbeiter eine
bessere Auslastung ihr Ratschlag an
andere Unternehmer einfach mal über den
Tellerrand hinaus denken denn ich war
auch kein Verfechter wird er vier Tage
Woche bevor ich diese Idee hatte das zu
ändern aber man muss sich einfach mal
Gedanken machen wie kann man es ändern
warum finden Unternehmen und Bewerber
nicht zusammen starre Arbeitsbedingungen
niedrige Löhne steuerliche Bremsen der
sogenannte Fachkräftemangel aktuell zum
größten Teil hausgemacht
[Musik]